私は数年前までライターをしてました
だから言葉を使って表現することは得意です
でも最近は
言葉を使わないでメッセージを伝える
そのことに夢中になっています
言葉を使わないでメッセージを届ける方法はたくさんあります
写真
動画
音楽もそうですよね
それからジェスチャ
ダンスだ
そして
ファッション
装いも
言葉を使わないでメッセージを伝える手段です
今日の私の装い
[拍手]
単に目指したがリアか起きているわけではなかったということです
ご覧のようにあの赤ベコというのは福島のもう
代表的でますことで
会津が発祥の地ですその合図に尊敬の意を込めて
そして私は福島を本気で pr しているよというメッセージなんです伝わりました
でしょうか
tee
うん
先日
福島で
ファッショナブル福島というちょっと変わったファッションショーを友人の
スタイリストと一緒に開催しました
これは福島の魅力
特産物や観光地そういったものをファッションで表現しようというちょっと変わった
試みなんです
登場してくれたのは一般市民の人たちです
一般市民の人たちが例えば
福島競馬場それからもうも
それから土いうこけし
もちろん赤べこ
そういったものをファッションで表現してランウェイを歩いてもらいました
一番人気だったのが
こちらです
ご存知の方多いと思いますが福島の方はでも知らない人は多いと思います
いかにんじんです福島の郷土料理なんです
これはニンジンの細切りそれからするメーカーの細切りを
少尉出会えたとても素朴ですでもとっても美味しい
美味しいんですけれどもちょっと
地味なんですよねうん
これを華やかに発信するにはどうしたらいいか
ニンジンのオレンジ色以下の茶色
そしてこの細切りの形状
これをファッションで表すと
あ
これは福島市に住む中学生の佐藤さんですがこんな風にお母さんといかにんじん
ファッションでランウエーそう
歩いてございましたん
me
ええええええ
tan tan
かわいいでしょうんっ
いかにんじんのように地域では愛されているけれども外には広がっていない頃は
たくさんあります
そういうものもちょっと
表現方法を変えるだけで
たくさんの人に観ていただくチャンスが生まれますそしていかに子食べてみたい
そう思う人もいるでしょう実際に食べてほしいです本当に美味しいんです
地域の魅力を
いろんな表現方法で発信する
その方が伝わりやすい
そういうふうに思い始めたあるきっかけがありました
それは2年前です
私はその半年前に
長年住んだ東京から故郷の福島に戻ってきました
福島は東日本大震災から第一次原発の事故があって復興に向けて進んでいました
そして
私が住む福祉場所をはじめほとんどの所では安全に普通の暮らしをしていました
でもとても誤解されていました
福島ではいまだに
未だにマスクをして愛と歩けない私の誘引ですらそんな風に思っている人がいました
この誤解を解きたい
そこで動画を作ったんです
当時ファレルウィリアムスの happy
という曲が大ヒットしていました
そして同時にこの曲に合わせてハッピーのダンスを踊る
それを動画に取る
これも流行っていました
世界中のいろんな地域いろんな街でご当地ハッピーが造られました
それを見てそうだ
福島版の happy を作ろうそう思いました
そして
前の人に声をかけて協力してもらってダンスを踊ってもらいました
みんな快く
協力してくれましたん
駅駅長さんや市長さん
それから
お店の店主さん学生
旅館の女将さん
そういう普通の人が楽しそうに踊る動画でした
みんな本当に ea の手を取ってくれたおかげてそれから
あの福島がハッピーダンスを踊ってる
そういう話題性もあって動画はたくさんの人に紙幣をされてなんと100万回も再生さ
れました
そして驚いたのは世界中からたくさんコメントが寄せられたんです
福島ってこんな風なのそう頭ここに戻ってもらったんですけど
福島ってこんな風なの
なんかすごくいいよねぇ
行ってみたいきれいなところ誰
頑張ってね
本当にいろんな国からコメントが寄せられたんです
私はそれを見て福島の言及を伝えられたそれは言葉では多分難しかったと思う
ダンスみんなの表情
それを動画で発信したからたくさんの人が見てくれた
そういうふうに思いました
それから
どういうふうに地域の魅力を表現したらいいのかいつも考えていました
悩むこともありました
時には全く違う文化の人がその表現方法をよく知っていることがあります
彼らは
海外から来た留学生です
55東北というプロジェクトがあります
これは先代の大学に学んでいる海外からの留学生が
東北の魅力をソーシャルメディアで発信するというプロジェクトです
100人ぐらいアンバサダと言われる東北アンバサダーと言われる学生たちがいます
そのうちの5人が先日福島に行ってきてくれました
私は彼らを案内して
どんな風に発信するのかなというのを見ていました
とても面白かったですちょっと紹介します
これは喜多方市にある会津電力のをグニー発電所です
ご覧のようにメガソーラーこれでクリーンなエネルギーを発電しています
私はここに何度も行きましたが確かに素晴らしい景色のところだけれどもこのメガ
ソーラー自体は無機質で
あまり美しいとは思えなかった
でも彼らを案内した時ちょうど夕暮れでした
夕日がこの騒乱に反射してとても美しかったんです
すると彼らはこんなことを始めました
えっ
このソーラーの前でジャンプをお互いにジャンプしながら写真を撮り合うんです
するとこんな写真が出来上がりがしました
うんん
まったく別な場所のようです
何か未来を感じました
それからやはり喜多方市の三ノ倉というとこのひまわり畑に行きました
ここは250万ボムの木周りが植えられて
観光名所になっていますみんなこのひまわりの前で記念写真を撮るんです
こんな風にこれは私です
自分の記録としてはいいけれどもこれは広まる写真ではありません
そこでフィリピンから来た剛君とロシアから来た
消えさんがお互いに協力しながらこのひまわり畑で写真を撮っていました
こんなんですっ
全身で表してますね
それから
これは合区が撮った写真ですけど木谷さんはカビがピンク色で
この
ヒマワリの黄色とてもマッチして動きのある
写真ですよね
表現方法はたくさんありますでもまず始めなければ
なりませんよね
この方は佐藤さんと言って会津若松市に住む
製造業を営む方です
佐藤さんは私のソーシャルメディアの口座に来てくれました
課題がありました
3の場合のものを動画に撮って
facebook に投稿してくださいそういう課題でした
佐藤さんはそんなことはやったことはありません
でご覧のように鮎釣りが趣味の方です
佐藤さんが投稿した動画はこんな風でした
tan
やはりもつけますつけたのでこれからね釣りをしたいと思います
まずたいとそれますようにお願いします
うんっ
奇跡的車記事が入って便所
ジュピヨっ子あっぱれ
これ俺がフレン
世界いう別名してしまう
をやって来てよえっ機にこちらです
橋場ね悪いんだよ
やっほー
ben wong
me
さあ釣れました行ってきこれが先ほどのをてりゃいいですこのほかに行っ
かかりはいいですね
この時期にあると結構時間大きく体
を一緒のはいですね子連れました
こんな所で
ねはい
こんな感じです佐藤さんは形ででスマートフォン片手て愛を持ってスマートフォンが
こう水没するをしそうになりながら頑張って取ったそうです
で感想を聞くと私なまってるんですね
これが感想でしたっ
とても美しいところですよね私あの
釣りはやらないんですけど行ってみたくなりました
ここは南会津の稲川というところです
鮎釣りのメッカだそうです
でも私は知りませんでしたこんなところがあるなんて多分
鮎釣りの人はすごく知っているそして地域の人はよく知っている
だからみんな知ってるんだと佐藤さんも思っていました
でもしれません
知らない人多いですよね多分全国でもほとんど知られてません
これはどうしてですか
情報発信をしていないんじゃないでしょうか
今
地方はどんどん人口が減少しています
産業がなくて若者が外に出ています
観光客もなかなかやって来てくれません
みんな言います
田舎は何もないから
牛の周りには何もないから
でも本当でしょうか
気がついていないだけでじゃないでしょうかそして発信をしていないだけじゃない
でしょうか
スマートフォンを持っている人は多いと思います
スマートフォンで何をしますか
もしかしたら情報を受け取るだけのものになっていませんか
もしそうだとしたら
使い方が間違っています
少なくとも都会ならいいです少なくとも地方で活性化したいそう思っている地方の人
たちならスマートフォンは発信するためのものです
何も難しい事を入らないんです佐藤さんみたいに
身の回りのものを発信するだけでいいそして佐藤さんみたいな人が5人10人
そして100人いたら
変わると思いませんか
地域にとって情報発信はとてもとても大事です
まず知ってもらわなければいけないそれにはスマートフォンを
何度もいますスマートフォンは発信するためのものです
一緒に発信しましょう
ありがとうございましたあ
[拍手]